what is Biden done to improve the lives
of all Americans did Biden pass criminal
justice reform no did he pass police
reform no that would have been President
Trump on both those issues and by the
way after Baltimore after Ferguson what
did Barack and Joe do nothing who
changed it president Trump changed it
did Barack and Joe create opportunities
owns and struggling neighborhoods no
that would be President Trump President
Trump has been in office as I said less
than four years and during that time pre
coronavirus record after record low
unemployment and for african-americans
Hispanic Americans Asian Americans women
in the workplace youth unemployment and
african-american youth unemployment
that's great for our collective American
family recently the president took
important steps to restore order in
American cities including those tough
measures against vandals those who have
been attempting to tear down any and
every statute across the country by the
way where does Joe stand on these issues
I know Terry McAuliffe wants him hiding
in the basement I'm fine with him there
he only sees two people a day and when
he stepped out for five seconds last
Thursday what did he do he talked about
a hundred and twenty million Americans
that died from Colvin where does Biden
stand what do you see our montage later
tonight does he want the statutes of
these generals and Lincoln and Jefferson
and Washington torn down where does Joe
stand on this does Joe support Princeton
University stripping the name Woodrow
Wilson from its international affairs
school because of President Wilson's
quote racist thinking what does Joe
thing what about Planned Parenthood we
you the taxpayers we spent hundreds of
millions of dollars funding Planned
Parenthood you know Margaret singer the
clinic well should be should that be
renamed as well because Sanger founded
Planned Parenthood in the early 20th
century Sanger was a well-known racist
and eugenicist guess what arguing in
favor of population control among poor
people also those with mental and
physical handicaps and others who
struggled in society she once wrote
quote we do not want the word to go out
that we want to exterminate the bleep
african-american population Sanger once
took her
message of population control and
presented it guess we're at a Ku Klux
Klan rally Joe Biden where do you stand
on Planned Parenthood in its founder
Margaret Sanger where do you stand on
the American taxpayer funding such an
organization and by the way buildings
named after her do we want to go there
to witness Joe stand there American
taxpayers gave around six hundred
million dollars you give annually to
Planned Parenthood why would taxpayers
give a dime to any such organization
what about the Russell Senate building
named after a prominent Democrat also a
known segregationist in their decades in
the Capitol why haven't Biden Pelosi and
Schumer the hundred and twenty five
years why haven't they done any of these
things and by the way then there's the
former Klansmen that was the head of the
Democratic Party for the United States
Senate for all those years
Robert KKK bird Biden praised and
eulogized the food's former colleague
Biden said that he held him in
incredible esteem Pelosi called Byrd
quote a great American patriot Schumer
he also praised on senator Byrd without
a doubt this represents the complicated
seedy hypocritical history of what is
the Democratic Party they would like
America to forget for example Biden once
worked side by side with segregationist
including the former Klansmen during a
speech in 1973 Joe Biden praised
Southern Democrats and said that the
two-party system in the South was quote
good for beep and around the same time
Biden was actively working with D
segregationist to slow integration by
opposing school busing according to NBC
News quote he led the charge on an issue
that kept black students away from the
classrooms of white students 1977 Biden
worried his children would grow up in
his words a racial jungle if integration
is not done in an orderly way 1993
referred to inner-city young people as
predators on our streets and as he
co-authored an aggressive crime bill
that ramped up prison sentences for
dozens of crimes that's where a lot of
disparate sentencing came into play and
that's what Donald Trump fixed predators
on our streets
yeah really Joe
Biden's rhetoric well that didn't stop
in the 90s 2006 he's the one that said
you have to have a slight Indian accent
if you want to work at a 7-eleven or
Dunkin Donuts
you also bragged that his state Delaware
was a slave state
he also said about Barack Obama this is
the first the first mainstream African
American who's actually articulate
bright and clean said it's storybook man
his words
20:19 he bragged about his work with
segregationist to get things done in the
US Senate last year he said quote poor
kids could be just as bright as white
kids okay Joe weeks ago he Biden told
the radio host Charlemagne the god quote
you eight black unless you're supporting
him over Donald Trump it's pretty
obvious why Biden spends yeah all of
that time and his basement bunker
because every time he pops his head out
he can barely string two sentences
together he's constantly making weird
statements many of them racial in nature
and it's only getting worse as Biden
ages now many are wondering Joe Biden is
he really fit to serve as the commander
in chief asked this question in 1984
about Ronald Reagan but does Joe Biden
have the mental alertness does he have
the stamina does he have the strength to
take on what is the hardest job in the
world and by the way what's going to
happen when he finally has to leave his
basement bunker for good and when will
the media after eighty eight days
without a press conference start
demanding that he do so a Rasmussen poll
just out shows thirty eight percent of
all voters think that Biden has some
form of dementia and that includes
twenty percent of Democratic voters
well the mob and the media will they ask
Biden the same questions they asked
Reagan about age and mental acuity and
don't hold your breath because guess
what in fact don't expect Biden to leave
the basement they're not even asking him
to